president biden shouts at the
unvaccinated slanders republican
governors and announces a federal
vaccine mandate without any legal
authority i'm ben shapiro this is the
bench bureau show
[Music]
this show is sponsored by expressivevpn
don't like bigtech and the government's
spying on you visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first let me just remind you
that your cell phone bill you know there
are a lot of things in life that tend to
go down your cell phone bill is not one
of those things it tends to rise over
time which is why every month you don't
look at that cell phone bill and then
you look at your credit card statements
and at the end of the year you're like
whoa i'm paying that much for my cell
phone coverage instead why not shift
over to pure talk usa last month an
absolute landslide if you made the
switch over to peer talk you were
chained to an overpriced unlimited plan
from verizon or rtnt or t-mobile and you
finally decided you know what enough is
enough and you made the switch you know
that pure talk saves the average family
over 800 a year without having to
sacrifice coverage so if you're one of
the people who haven't made the switch
yet what exactly are you waiting for you
can keep your phone keep your number or
get huge discounts on the latest iphones
and androids i got the iphone 12. let me
just make this clear you're not
sacrificing coverage with fear talk
because again you're using the exact
same network as one of the big cell
phone companies these guys invest a
fortune into making sure you have the
latest tech and they just pass that
savings on to you get a limited talk
text and six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month or if you still want
unlimited data you can get that as well
and you'll still be saving a fortune
over the other guys just dial pound 250
say ben shapiro you will save 50 off
your very first month that's pound two
five zero say ben shapiro pure talk is
simply smarter wireless okay let's be
real about this joe biden is a failed
president he's a failed president he
failed in afghanistan and he blames
everybody else
he has failed on the economy and he
blames everybody else and he has failed
on covet and so he blames everybody else
and what this necessitates is joe biden
making policy moves that are unlikely to
result in any sort of serious
improvement for the american people but
are simply designed to shift blame away
from himself so just like the americans
stuck in afghanistan eventually said the
administration are there because they
want to be there right it's their fault
that they are stuck they're not our
fault for running the worst
design surrender in modern american
history
nope it's really not about that it's
about the americans stuck there it's
their fault in the same way joe biden's
failure to prevent the the vaccine
the vaccine mandates and the mass
mandates from being promulgated in blue
areas and therefore shutting down the
economy his unwillingness to recognize
when we have reached the end of a
pandemic and it has now just become
endemic his failures there have now
necessitated that he take this extremely
harsh action that is unlikely to ever be
implemented because frankly no one is
going to comply
so we'll get into the policy of this in
just one second and why i say that this
thing is never going to be implemented
on a wide scale white is likely to be
struck down why it's almost
unenforceable even were it not to be
struck down but
last night joe biden made the most
authoritarian move that i have seen in
the last 10 15 20 years of american
politics i'm having a hard time picking
it exactly because we've seen
authoritarian moves before very often it
turns out democratic presidents have a
bad habit of saying i don't have the
power to do x and then five seconds
later they just do it so you remember
barack obama said over and over and over
i don't have the power to simply stop
enforcing immigration law and then you
just did it and you'll remember that joe
biden said i don't have the power to
issue an eviction moratorium via the
centers for disease control and then he
just did it
well you'll recall that this
administration has over and over and
over said they do not have the power to
issue any sort of a vaccine mandate
here's joe biden back in december of
last year saying he didn't agree with
the idea of a federal vaccine mandate
this is after the election
no i don't think it should be mandatory
i wouldn't demand to be mandatory but i
would do everything in my power just
like i don't think masks have to be made
mandatory nationwide i'll do everything
in my power as
a president united states to encourage
people to do the right thing and when
they do it demonstrate that it matters
okay so that was back in december and
then in july his own press secretary
john saki said don't worry there's not
going to be a federal vaccine mandate
we're not even thinking about that liars
liars liars because again as soon as
things got bad it was time for joe biden
to shift blame again that's what this
policy is really about his entire policy
here is about shifting blame from
himself and his failures of policy to
the unvaccinated so here is jen saki
back in july saying no vaccine mandate
perhaps the federal government should
step in and issue mandates and if not
are you putting the needs of
unvaccinated people ahead of the needs
of vaccinated people well i think the
question here one that's not the role of
the federal government um that is the
role that institutions private sector
entities uh and others may take that
certainly is appropriate that literally
is not the role of the federal
government says gensake well until
yesterday at which point the biden
administration seeking to shift blame
away from afghanistan and focus away
from afghanistan and seeking to shift
blame away from the economic stagnation
shifted away from the administration
decided the people you really should
hate are your fellow americans those are
the people you should hate the
unvaccinated who live next door to you
those are the people you should hate and
this brings me back to a point that i've
made one million times at this point the
worried in america the people who are
deeply worried about covet at this point
are almost entirely the vaccinated which
is insane once you're vaccinated you
should not be worried about whether your
neighbor is unvaccinated it makes no
difference to you
if this notion that you should be
walking around in abject fear because
your neighbor is unvaccinated is totally
crazy it is unmoored from scientific
reality first of all the vaccinated are
capable of infecting other people second
of all once you're vaccinated your
chances of hospitalization or death are
extraordinarily low because again the
vaccines are incredibly effective you
want to make people hesitant about
vaccine keep telling them that even
after you're vaccinated the unvaccinated
might infect you and you might die
it's a completely mixed confused message
but again it is not about consistency it
is not about efficacy it is not about
actually achieving more vaccines right
all this is is about shifting blame away
from joe biden being a failure of a
president the economic stagnation that
we are seeing is not in fact the result
of the delta variants the economic
stagnation that we are seeing is a pure
result of bad policy being made in blue
states and by the federal government
it's about the media scaring the living
hell out of people so they don't want to
go to stores it's about people in blue
states saying you can't go back to work
because even if you're vaccinated you
might get sick again
there is a reason i keep repeating this
because it's true there is a reason that
all of the best states in america in
terms of unemployment rate are red and
all of the worst states in america in
terms of unemployment rate are blue
there is a reason for that it is because
a huge swath of this country has been
completely
disconnected from the reality of the
science disconnected from the reality of
the statistics and so joe biden is now
saying you need to blame your neighbor
don't blame me for the lockdowns don't
blame me for the mandates blame your
neighbor it's their fault that i'm doing
this
or maybe it's your fault for doing it
maybe it's your fault for doing it you
can see the blame shifting in real time
it's ugly and it is un-american it's
un-american to say i have to take this
policy against you
because your fellow americans are doing
something bad so now i'm taking this
policy and i'm doing it against all of
you
and you should hate your neighbor right
it's the full metal jacket style
governance right somebody in your
barracks didn't do the proper thing so
now all of you have to do push-ups and
later you can go over to that guy and
put some soap in a bed sheet and beat
the living hell out of him
that is joe biden's style of governance
it is in fact un-american and it's
evidence that he is a failure as both a
president and as a decent human being
with the kind of power that he's
attempting to wield
in one second we'll get to joe biden's
ridiculous and horrifying speech frankly
the stuff that he was saying yesterday
there
is there a low for biden there is no
floor there really is not i thought that
the worst speech that i'd heard was the
speech that he gave like last week upon
the withdrawal from afghanistan where he
championed himself and pat himself on
the back while hundreds of americans
were still stuck behind enemy lines fast
forward one week and now he's calling
his fellow americans treating them as is
his subjects they're not citizens
anymore they are just the people that he
gets to order around and if they don't
do what he says he will force them to do
what what he says
and it is dictatorial authoritarian
stuff it really is amazing we'll get to
that in just one second first
let us talk about the fact that look
around your house right now look around
your living room that's pretty nice
right you redecorated it not all that
long ago there's something about it
that's still like a little off right
it's a little dingy it's your window
coverings i know you haven't thought
about that you still have the old
curtains from the person who lived in
your house before you bought it or your
apartment before you rented it but if
you change the window coverings you can
change the way light comes into the room
it really does change the entire look
and feel of your house or of your
apartment this is why you should check
out blinds.com blinds.com makes it
simple to shop top quality custom blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and free
shipping the experts at blinds.com
understand that window treatments are
one of those household items you don't
think about but they can make a huge
impact on the look and feel of your home
you don't need to do a full renovation
by simply changing what's on your
windows you can change the way light
comes into your home and create a
totally different feel go to blinds.com
just take a look at all the options like
faux wood blinds cellular and roller
shades even outdoor shades
all customizable to your specific
dimensions and if you're nervous about
trying them their sure-fit guarantee has
you covered blinds.com has helped
millions of homeowners through the
process and they guarantee that perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or have
them measure and install everything for
you i really appreciate blindness.com
you will too go right now see how much
you can save at blinds.com when you
check out online don't forget to tell
them you heard about blinds.com from the
ben shapiro show rules and restrictions
may apply alrighty so last night joe
biden wanders out to the microphone
about five o'clock in the afternoon
because again he has to make that early
bird special over at denny's and he
proceeds to yell at you his grandpa
simpson yelling at the clouds he's going
to yell at you if you're unvaccinated
and you know he's going to yell at you
if you're vaccinated too because the
fact is if you were just madder at your
neighbor if you were more angry at the
person who lives next door to you then
that would fix the country
so he starts off by talking about how
frustrated he is with the people who are
still not vaccinated right again
this is a free country
where it used to be and i'm not angry at
the people who aren't vaccinated i'm not
again i am very pro-vaccine i've told
everybody in my office i think they
ought to get the vaccine many of them
didn't listen that is their business
that doesn't make me angry because i'm
not a tyrant joe biden is a tyrant so it
makes him super angry when people don't
listen to him and the people that it
impacts
are the people who didn't listen to him
again this would be one thing if the
unvaccinated were actually posing a
danger to the people who are vaccinated
they are not
but that mixed message was completely
elided here because again this is not
about anything other than joe biden is a
damned coward who wants to shift the
blame for his own failures onto the
backs of other americans so here he is
many of us are frustrated with the
nearly 80 million americans who are
still not vaccinated
even though the vaccine is safe
effective and free okay how about the
americans who have natural immunity
there's studies after studies showing
that natural immunity is more durable
than vaccine immunity and yet there are
no
there are no provisions in jobiden's
proposed rule for people who have
antibodies for people who already have
natural immunity
none because this isn't about science
it's about yelling at people
he continues along these lines he just
kept hammering this over and over if
you're unvaccinated it's your fault i'm
doing this it's your fault that i'm
hurting everybody right so that
it's not my fault i'm hurting you it's
your fault that i'm hurting you here's
joe biden
the vast majority of americans are doing
the right thing
nearly three-quarters of the eligible
have gotten at least one shot
but one quarter has not gotten any
that's nearly 80 million americans not
vaccinated
and a country as large as ours that's 25
minority that 25 can cause a lot of
damage and they are to whom
to whom
to the 25
right he which joe biden freely admits
in this is how you know that he's a
dishonest lying sack
this is how you know it right because
when he says that they're causing a lot
of damage again the rule of
externalities right which is where
government very often comes into play is
i can wave my fist around until it hits
you in the face and that is the general
rule of externalities what it but what
joe biden is now saying is that he gets
to intervene if i wave my fist around
and it hits me in the face
if you're unvaccinated you're not a
danger to the vaccinated you know who
knows this joe biden who said it last
night
i want to emphasize
that the vaccines provide very strong
protection
from severe illness from covert 19.
i know there's a lot of confusion and
misinformation
but the world's leading scientists
confirm
that if you are fully vaccinated your
risk of severe illness from covet 19 is
very low
in fact
based on available data from the summer
only one out of every 160 000 fully
vaccinated americans
was hospitalized for covert per day
so what the hell are you trying to yell
at people for i don't understand i'm
vaccinated again i do not give
you can ask the people in my office as
soon as i was two weeks out from my
final vaccination i came into the office
and people had been masking up right
that many of the people in the office
have been masking because i was
concerned about me getting it and
transmitting my parents who are 65 i
wasn't particularly worried about me
getting sick but i was worried about
transmitting to my parents
and
then i came in and people said you know
do you want us to wear the mask i said
first of all like i never told you you
had to wear the mask but if you want to
take it off i really don't care now like
i really don't care because it doesn't
matter to me joe biden is saying it
shouldn't matter to you once you are
vaccinated you are safe
but you should still be angry at the
unvaccinated
right he just continues along these
lines it makes no sense here he is
saying another incoherent nonsensical
thing for the vast majority of you
who've gotten vaccinated i understand
your anger
at those who haven't gotten vaccinated
i understand the anxiety about getting a
breakthrough case
but as the science makes clear
if you're fully vaccinated
you're highly protected from severe
illness
even if you get covet 19.
in fact recent data indicates
there is only one confirmed positive
case per 5 000 fully vaccinated
americans per day
you're as safe as possible
and we're doing everything we can to
keep it that way keep it that way keep
you safe okay so
so this old man is telling you that
you're safe once you're vaccinated but
then he says this he says now you're not
safe so on the one hand you're safe
because you got vaccinated on the other
hand you're unsafe now let me ask why is
he saying you're unsafe the reason he's
saying you're unsafe is because he wants
the lockdowns he wants the mandates he
wants those things so he can justify his
failed economic policies so he can
justify a turn away from your focus on
afghanistan and so that he can justify
you being angry not at him but it's
somebody else be mad at anybody just not
joe biden this is the biden doctrine in
a nutshell be angry at everybody except
for joe biden
it's more of this cowardice in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that there are still 10 million open
jobs in the united states the lockdowns
in the last year and a half created
pent-up demand for places like gyms nail
salons and hotels all of them are on an
epic hiring spree to accommodate this
surge of business there aren't enough
employees to keep up with the number of
open slots so where do businesses turn
to fill these roles fast they turn to
zip recruiter right now you can try it
for free at ziprecruiter.com dailywire
when you post a job on zip recruiter
they send your job to over 100 top job
sites giving you access to their network
of millions of job seekers zip
recruiters matching technology scans
resumes to find qualified candidates for
your open roles and then proactively
presents them to you
you can easily review recommended
candidates and invite your top choices
to apply for your job and that
encourages them to apply faster
according to zip recruiter internal data
jobs where employers invite candidates
to apply get two and a half times more
candidates zip recruiters technology is
so effective four out of five employers
who post unzip recruiter get a quality
candidate within the very first day
there's a reason we here at daily wire
have been using zip recruiter for years
right now you can try zip recruiter for
free at this exclusive web address
ziprecruiter.com dailywire that's
ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e just go to zip
recruiter.com daily why are zip
recruiters indeed the smartest way to
hire again go check them out right now
zippercrew.com
dailywire okay so
he says you're safe right you're safe
from covet
but then he says you're not safe from
covered so you're safe but not so safe
you're super safe guys the vaccine is
great and it works fantastic also you're
deeply unsafe from your colleagues which
is why we have to restrict all of you
it's why we have to restrict them
they're the bad guys
right we have to we have to make sure
that you don't work as a vaccinated
person next to an unvaccinated person
here's joe biden saying incoherent
nonsense as per his usual routine
the bottom line
we're going to protect vaccinated
workers from unvaccinated co-workers
we're going to reduce the spread of
covet 19 by increasing the share of the
workforce that is vaccinated in
businesses all across america he just
said if you're vaccinated you're safe
now he's saying if you're vaccinated you
have to be protected from your
unvaccinated co-workers again this is
about yelling at people who are not joe
biden
and then he continues to just berate
unvaccinated by the way if you want to
get unvaccinated americans to vaccinate
you know what you don't do you get on tv
you don't get on tv and yell at them
about how dumb they are you try to
convince them you try to actually work
with them you try to get them to go see
a doctor who's going to tell them you
say listen go you're an individual go to
your doctor and ask what's best for you
and let the doctor do the work right
there are things that you can do to
convince unvaccinated americans to get
vaccinated and then there's going to be
a hardcore people who don't want to get
vaccinated and that's their choice that
is their prerogative because as joe
biden says if you are vaccinated you are
safe if you are vaccinated you are safe
that is what the science says but now
we're going to implement policies based
on the precise reverse that if you're
vaccinated you're somehow not safe okay
so again he's just gonna yell more at
the unvaccinated it's unreal
my message to unvaccinated americans is
this
what more is there to wait for
what more do you need to see
we've made vaccinations free
safe and convenient
the vaccine has fda approval
over 200 million americans have gotten
at least one shot
we've been patient
but our patience is wearing thin
and your refusal has cost all of us
no
it hasn't
it has not it has cost the other
unvaccinated your refusal has i live in
florida you know what the unvaccinated
refusal has has cost me
nothing
nothing it hasn't cost me except for
some dictatorial idiots in the
bureaucracy who insist that we mask kids
for no apparent data reason
or some idiot some idiotic bureaucratic
ninis who think that they get to mandate
that you can't go into a business or
something okay and that's their choice
okay that is that is the choice of the
bureaucracy if you don't like the rules
coming from the bureaucrats that's the
fault of the bureaucrats that is not the
fault of the people who live next door
to you who don't think like you do about
the vaccine
the attempt to i keep coming back to
this it is such cowardice it's
unbelievable cowardice here from the
president of the united states
and then he continues along these lines
and he decides he's going to yell at
elected officials right he's going to
say it's not just the unvaccinated
that's not the biggest problem the
biggest problem is also that we have
governors governors who are not pushing
vaccinations now i have a question which
governor isn't pushing vaccinations can
you name a single one
ronda sanchez has been pushing
vaccinations since day one in fact
there's a 60 minutes article
a 60-minute story about how terrible ron
desantis was such a terrible human being
for vaccinating the elderly first and
getting publics to disseminate the
vaccine
so republican governors abbot
lee
gnome desantis they have all been
pushing the vaccine they have all been
saying that you should get the vaccine
so it is not about republican governors
not saying you should get the vaccine
every single one has pushed the vaccine
so far as i am aware
it is about the fact that they are not
mandating masks it's about the fact that
they still want you to be able to live
your life which is why their states are
doing better economically speaking than
blue states that joe biden agrees with
so on the one hand he is saying if
you're vaccinated you're safe and if
you're unvaccinated the pandemic applies
to you on the other hand he is saying
damn it these these stupid red state
governors and their unwillingness to
protect the unvaccinated from the other
unvaccinated through mass mandates and
from the vaccinated through mass
mandates you can't have it both ways but
he is wanting to have it both ways so
here he is yelling at governors
what makes it incredibly more
frustrating
is that we have the tools to combat
covert 19
and a distinct minority of americans
supported by a stink minority of elected
officials are keeping us from turning
the corner
these pandemic politics as i refer to
are meg are making people sick
causing unvaccinated people to die
we cannot allow these actions
to stand in the way of protecting the
large majority of americans who have
done their part
i want to get back to life as normal
this is orwellian it's
unbelievable he said okay so he is
saying that if you don't put down a mask
mandate you're causing unvaccinated
people to die no you are not the unvet
according to joe biden himself one
second ago okay within the last second
according to joe biden the unvaccinated
are causing the unvaccinated to die by
not vaccinating
mandating masks isn't causing or failure
to mandate masks is not causing the
unvaccinated to die the unvaccinated not
vaccinating is causing the unvaccinated
to die and when he says we can't allow
these actions to stand in the way of
protecting the majority of americans
who've done their part and want to get
back to life as normal i've been back to
life as normal since day that i got
vaccinated so have my parents so is
everybody else vaccinated who is not out
of their damned mind the minute you got
vaccinated you were good to go
but according joe biden says that he
says it and then he's still like no no
in order to prevent my authoritarian
mandates we have to go after these
unvaccinated people it's their fault i'm
doing this to you
joe biden is now the seven-year-old kid
with the four-year-old little brother
taking the four-year-old's hand smacking
the four-year-old in the face and going
why are you hitting yourself why are you
hitting yourself
that is who the president of the united
states is he is hitting you
this is his stupid policy it makes no
sense
and and then he continues along these
lines going after other elected
officials
to make matters worse
for elected officials
actively working to undermine the fight
against covet 19.
instead of encouraging people to get
vaccinated in a mask up
they're ordering mobile morgues
for the unvaccinated dying from coven in
their communities
this is totally unacceptable who is the
governor who is not urging people to get
vaccinated
notice how he slipped in and mask up
but again why should the vaccinated mask
up to protect the unvaccinated who have
made the choice not to get vaccinated
and we'll get to his policy in a second
because his policy is utterly again
disconnected from constitutional reality
or from enumerated powers basically we
now live under the auspices of an
administrative blob that can do whatever
the whatever the hell it wants to you at
any time based on vague authorities
granted to it by a cowardly congress
over the course of the last 50 years
that's what we live under we live under
the dictatorship of the of the
bureaucracy
it's it's i mean the paper pushers run
the country at the behest of old senile
men yelling at you we'll get some more
at this in one second it's outrageous
first let us talk about the fact that
you need home insurance right in a lot
of places you actually have to have home
insurance in order to buy a home well
it's never a bad time to find ways to
bundle your home and auto insurance and
save on coverage with policy genius
policy genius makes it easy to compare
home and auto insurance all in one place
they can help you find home and auto
coverage similar to what you have now
but at a lower price they've saved
customers an average of 1 250 bucks per
year over what they were paying for home
and auto insurance they save new
customers an average of 435 bucks per
year on auto insurance they've saved new
customers an average of 350 bucks per
year on home insurance their team will
handle the paperwork to set up your new
policy or switch over your current one
getting started is simple first you head
on over to policygenius.com shapiro home
and you answer a few quick questions
about yourself and your property then
policy genius takes it from there
they'll compare rates from america's top
insurers from progressive to allstate
and find your lowest quotes the policy
genius team can look for ways to save
you more including bundling your home
and auto policies if they find a better
rate than what you're paying now they'll
switch you over for free their top-notch
service has earned policy genius
thousands of five-star reviews across
trustpilot and google head on over to
policygenius.com shapirohome to get
started writes this very instant policy
genius when it comes to insurance it's
nice and quite important to get it right
okay finally we get to joe piden's
policies so up till now we've just been
talking about his approach his approach
is simultaneously if you're vaccinated
you're safe but also you're super unsafe
from the unvaccinated also governors who
urge you to get vaccinated are bad
because they also didn't urge you to
mask because we have to protect the
unvaccinated from the vaccinated even
what we're actually trying to do is get
the unvaccinated vaccinated
this is his approach and by the way all
the policies that i am cramming down on
you are the faults of your fellow
americans not my fault
that that is what the president of the
united states this this doddling fool is
saying to you then we get to the actual
policy and the policy is not only
nonsensical it completely runs roughshod
over the constitutional division between
the federal government and states
so let's be clear about this states do
have enormous power in the area of
public health the federal government
does not
the reason the federal government does
not is because typically speaking the
founding fathers did not want to give a
giant overarching public health
bureaucracy the ability to mandate
things on millions of americans
the notion that the federal government
could using an administrative
bureaucracy without any congressional
action simply crammed down on some 100
million americans working at companies
that have over 100 employees a mandate
that they either get tested every week
or get vaccinated or get fired
and the threat to fine every company 14
grand for every violation which is the
threat to bankrupt every major company
or mid-sized major company in the united
states
now that is the notion you could do that
without any sort of congressional
approval
let alone any sort of constitutional
edifice to support this on it just
demonstrates that the administrative
bureaucracy really runs the country and
that our country is no longer run by
elected officials
and basically you have a dictator who
sits at the top of the executive branch
and he tells his lawyers to go find some
excuse in some vaguely worded enabling
document for a three-letter bureaucracy
or four-letter bureaucracy
and just go do what i want
that's the way government is now run we
elect our dictator once every four years
and then he just tells the the
entrenched bureaucracy to go find an
excuse for him to do whatever the hell
he wants
and then we wait for the courts to maybe
save us or maybe not
okay so joe biden begins his
announcement of what these vaccine
policies are gonna look like and we're
gonna go through the details of his
vaccine policies in just one second
he uh he begins it by saying this isn't
about freedom or personal choice
um yes
it is
yes it is it would not be about freedom
of personal choice if you were talking
about externalities to other people who
had no capacity to protect themselves
right i'm not allowed to pollute a river
and then say that that is freedom or
personal choice because other people
drink from the river i am allowed to say
i do not wish to
protect myself from this thing for
whatever reason so long as it is not
affecting you
that's the whole point once the
vaccinations are in place it is not
affecting anybody who wants to be
protected but here is joe biden denying
it's about freedom of personal choice
because again he gets to tell you what
freedom or personal choice constitute
freedom is what he says it is personal
choice is what he says it is me running
my business the way i see fit and
allowing my employees to live the way
they see fit
that is not freedom freedom is him
telling us what to do
freedom extends just as far as joe
biden's grasp
here is joe biden on this particular
topic
this is not about freedom
or personal choice
it's about protecting yourself and those
around you
the people you work with
the people you care about the people you
love
my job as president is to protect all
americans
so tonight
i'm announcing that the department of
labor
is developing an emergency rule
to require all employers with 100 or
more employees
that together employ over 80 million
workers
to ensure their workforces
are fully vaccinated
or show a negative test at least once a
week okay so his policy is now that via
the department of labor and osha
right the via a four-letter bureaucracy
they are going to tell every major
business in the united states
that you need to either force your
workers to get vaccinated or
force them to show a negative test at
least once a week
right this is this is his proposal now
how exactly is this going to be
implemented nobody knows he doesn't make
any of this clear and in fact members of
the media are asking about it
first of all there are um as we'll see
in a second there are a bunch of
exceptions to his rule it turns out that
if you're a special meaning if you work
for the federal government and you have
a union then you're protected but if
you're a private business owner he is
going to screw you beyond imagining
he's threatening again a 14 000 fine for
every person who is not forced to comply
with the vaccine or testing regimen so
we have like 200 employees daily where
let's say 100 of them are vaccinated and
100 aren't so according to joe biden if
we at daily wire refuse to test these
people once a week and show negative
tests or force them to get vaccinated
then
every single violation for every single
employee every single week is findable
to the tune of 14 000 which means
last i checked if that's 100 employees
you're talking about 1.4 million dollars
a week
a week right so he's getting bankrupt
every business in america what that's
going to require is an enormous huge new
bureaucracy whose
whose job it is to just monitor all
these businesses doing their reporting
requirements or they're gonna have to
send people down to make sure that you
are not actually
you're not actually falsifying the data
and this
this is truly totalitarian sort of stuff
here
okay now again there are exceptions to
his rule
exceptions to his rule as it turns out
include people who work for public
sector unions according to the
washington post
u.s postal service workers were not
included in biden's executive order
requiring all federal employees to get
vaccinated against the coronavirus
according to a white house official
speaking on the condition of anonymity
to discuss not yet public portions of
the president's plan
now this is one of the elements of the
president's plans for the private sector
for the private sector the law for the
public sector everything
right so joe biden says he's going to
sign an executive order and it's going
to require all executive
branch federal employees to be
vaccinated except for the ones who you
know we have deals with
next
i will sign an executive order
that will now require all executive
branch federal employees to be
vaccinated all
i've signed another executive order that
will require federal contractors
to do the same
if you want to work with the federal
government and do business with us get
vaccinated because first of all he's
lying for a huge swath of workers
according to the washington post 644 000
employees you know the people who bring
your mail every day the people who are
most likely to be in contact with you
joe american every single day those
people are not going to have to get
vaccinated or do the testing regimen
because they have a union the american
postal workers union
and that union gives a lot of money to
democrats
so that means that the postal service is
now exempt
also according to the washington post
the largest union representing federal
workers pushed back against the
specifics of implementation according to
the washington post
everett kelly president of the american
federation of government employees says
quote changes like this should be
negotiated with our bargaining units
where appropriate put simply workers
deserve a voice in their working
conditions so in all likelihood if there
is a union deal with the federal
government the unions will be exempted
so basically if you're in the private
sector you are screwed is the way that
joe biden is is going to attempt to
implement this
tyrannical tyrannical we're going to get
to by the way the legality of all this
in just one second after we get through
the policy so he begins with the
proposition that if you're a private
employer with over 100 employees then
he's gonna force you to either force
your employees to be vaccinated or get
tested once a week and provide a
negative cover test whether they are
symptomatic or asymptomatic
or fire them right that is going to be
your job as an employer who's going to
pay for this doesn't make clear
so if you're an employer who has 100
first of all if you're if you're an
employer with 100 employees you're just
going to fire two people right then
you're not subject to the mandate
okay second how are you actually going
to pay for the testing regimen okay
because these tests aren't free they
cost 50 100 bucks depending on the kind
of test you are doing so you're talking
about adding a burden to mid-sized
businesses that may be their entire
profit margin
let's say that you have 200 employees
right you're a solid size business but
you're not like a massive business you
have 200 employees and let's say it
costs 50 bucks
per employee
to do these tests so you're talking
about ten thousand dollars a week to do
these tests so that's forty thousand
dollars a month that's not an
insignificant amount of money
and so what are people going to do what
are you going to force your employees to
pay for the tests
just going to up prices like this is
none of this and again he's doing all of
this at a time when employers are facing
inflation they can't get enough people
to actually come back to work in the
first place
okay so that's bad policy then he's got
his executive order with regard to
federal employees which as we've
discussed doesn't apply to all federal
employees
okay it doesn't stop there
he also says that he's going to
encourage people running large
entertainment venues not to allow people
in who are unvaccinated
so now we're going to check your card at
all of the broadway shows and all of the
movie theaters the movie theaters by the
way are struggling to come back as it is
so now he's saying
he he wants them to issue a vaccine
mandate with regards to their own
customers
he wants college football stadiums to
start checking vaccine cards at the door
good luck with this bob
and for other sectors
i issue this appeal
to those of you running large
entertainment venues
from sports arenas to concert venues to
movie theaters please require folks to
get vaccinated
or show a negative test as a condition
of entry
amazing
okay and uh he didn't stop there he also
wants boosters by the way in
contravention of two of his top members
of his own fda and the who
we'll get to that in just one second
first let us talk about the fact that if
you are looking to make your business
better you really need to take a look at
podium why well because the simple fact
is that the way that you communicate
with your customers matters if you give
them a phone call very often they're
just going to send you to voicemail if
you attempt to email them it might just
go right into the junk file instead why
not use text messaging this is what
podium helps people do that's why more
than 90 000 local businesses of all
sizes have turned a podium whether you
have one location or 1 000 podium can
help you stay ahead podium makes doing
business as easy as sending a text
because when texts get open business
gets done all your employees can text
from a single inbox offering a smoother
experience for your customers if you're
answering questions you just send a text
collecting reviews send a text
scheduling an appointment or delivery
send a text payment collection send a
text again we use this sort of service
here at daily wire podium is important
for your business why wouldn't you reach
your customers the best way possible did
you know local service professionals
keep clients longer and collect payments
faster using text messages for example a
dentist in new york city had one million
dollars in overdue collections he sent
everybody a tax payment he collected 700
grand in two weeks today's customers
expect to on demand everything even from
local businesses stay ahead of your
competition with podium they have free
plans for growing businesses plus all
the power growing businesses need to
scale get started free today at
podium.com
shapiro that is podium.com
shapiro we'll get some more on joe
biden's unconstitutional and
authoritarian policies in just one
second first as we are discussing joe
biden's weaponization of osha to force
all companies with over 100 employees to
either mandate vaccines or test their
employees for cove at least once a week
is tyrannical and it's not just
tyrannical it is it is dictatorial in
extremis it is it is amazingly
dictatorial and as i say companies that
don't comply are going to face up to 14
000 bucks for each violation
they could be ruinous to businesses all
over the country who still want freedom
for their employees including the daily
wire as i say i'm vaccinated i encourage
vaccination we live in a free country
americans still have the right to make
their own decisions so we plan on
fighting joe biden's dictatorial mandate
with every resource at our disposal as a
company
so this is a battle it's going to be a
legal battle and we are calling on
everybody who's listening to help us
fight this obscene tyrannical mandate
and if you join as a daily wire member
right now it's self-serving but it's
true you will be giving us the resources
we need to take this all the way up to
the supreme court if necessary which by
the way may end up being quite a good
thing for the american public go to
dailywire.com subscribe use code do not
comply at checkout for 25 off americans
have been ceding their freedom and their
liberty to authoritarian bureaucrats in
the name of public health for way too
long enough is enough so stand up with
us at daily wire and perhaps most
importantly the rights of all american
citizens the coders do not comply to
become a member get 25 percent off
also this weekend we remember the men
and women who lost their lives 20 years
ago in the most brutal terror attack in
american history i sat down with one of
the politicians who shouldered much of
the political burden placed on the bush
administration in the aftermath on last
sunday's episode of the sunday special i
was joined by former secretary of state
condi rice she was an excellent moving
guest it's available now if you haven't
had the chance to check it out again if
you don't remember september 11th
because you're too young or if you do
remember september 11th but you don't
know where things went off the rails the
discussion with condi is must listening
so go stream it right now at daily wire
on the daily wire apple tv or roku app
or on my youtube channel ben shapiro
daily where members get access to
special bonus content from sunday
special episodes so don't miss out join
daily wire today you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so joe biden's big plans didn't
stop at forcing every business in the
united states with upward of 100
employees to force their employees to
vaccinate or test or to pressure
all large entertainment venues to
vaccine card everybody he also has now
said that he is going to be pushing
booster shots now here is the problem
there's very conflicting evidence on who
exactly should get booster shots and
just last week two top officials at the
fda resigned over the biden
administration's booster shot plan
right that of course is according to
business insider
dr marion gruber director of the fda's
office of vaccines research and review
and her deputy dr philip krauss planned
to leave the fda the fda in october and
november biocentury first reported the
news on tuesday
the reason that they left apparently is
because they didn't like the booster
shot plan the reason they didn't like
the booster shot plan is because the
biden administration announced it before
the fda had even done the research on it
okay so just think about this for a
second imagine if all of us were trump
remember trump was an authoritarian
dictator he's a tyrant and he was
wrecking all of the norms and
institutions and here you have joe biden
actually doing all this stuff and not a
peep so here's joe biden talking about
booster shots now listen i am not
anti-booster shots i think that the data
is highly variable based on your age if
you are 30 years old and you had two
shots i'm not sure that you need a third
shot if you're 65 maybe you need a shot
if you're 80 you probably do need a
third shot
okay but joe biden doesn't care about
any of that he's just throwing the wall
at this point to see what sticks
last month
our top government doctors announced
an initial plan for booster shots for
vaccinated americans
they believe that the booster is likely
to provide the highest level of
protection yet
of course
the decision
of which booster shots to give when to
start them and who will give them
will be left completely to the
scientists at the fda in the centers for
disease control
by the way uh do you believe that
literally two fta guys just stepped down
yesterday or last week rather because he
was interfering
in the same way they kept accusing trump
of interfering he's interfered over and
over and over again the cdc has set
standards based on the american
federation of teachers whims at the
behest of the biden administration
anthony fauci shifts his guidance every
single week based on what joe biden is
saying that week
you really believe these are independent
agencies and this is not me being
against booster shots this is me
pointing out that if you think this
administration is guided by anything
remotely resembling science you're out
of your damned mind this is all politics
all the way down for these guys which by
the way is why people are not getting
vaccinated because they don't trust
these people because they are political
in the extreme
they are political top to bottom like
why doesn't anyone trust us because
you're political hacks and you lie all
the damn time that's why and i'm
pro-vaccine i'm angry at you for keeping
people unvaccinated by lying to them for
a year
it's unreal by the way i'm old enough to
remember when the who was the gold
standard when it came to all of this
right if you contradicted the who on
youtube then this meant that youtube
would take you down the who has now said
that rich countries shouldn't be doing
booster shots
the who director tedros
gabrieles said he was appalled at the
decision by so many of these countries
to push booster shots in the face of
huge swaths of the global population
that don't actually have a coveted
vaccine yet
okay but joe biden didn't stop here troy
biden also went after the schools
so he uh he decided that he was going to
jab her about how we need to mask up at
schools again the data on masking at
schools does not exist there is no data
that masking at schools particularly
cloth masks does a damn bit of
difference there's not one study that
demonstrates this for schooling
here's joe biden pushing it anyway
we know that if schools follow the
science
and implement the safety measures like
testing
masking adequate ventilation systems
which we provided the money for
social distancing
and vaccinations
then children can be safe from covet 19
in schools
today
about 90 of school staffs and teachers
are vaccinated
we should get that to 100 okay so i have
a question here let's assume that he's
right for a second we need to get the
entire school staff vaccinated because
they're going to infect the kids or
something even though the stats show
that unvaccinated children there's new
british data unvaccinated kids are safer
from covid19 than vaccinated adults
that that is how non-deadly covet is to
people under the age of 18 in the united
states and abroad
okay well let's just say though that you
want to get 100 of the teachers
vaccinated so he just said every private
business in the united states
is going to be forced to get their
people vaccinated or to test once a week
why can't he do the same in public
schools after all it is a workplace is
it not the answer is he's not going to
do that because the american federation
of teachers doesn't want it he's not
going to do that because the nea might
protest it's all political it's all
political and how do you know that it's
all political because he took the time
once again to go after the governors and
to state by the way that he's just going
to run roughshod over the constitution
he's like if governors don't do what i
want i'm just gonna blow him down here
he goes
my plan also takes on elected officials
in states that are undermining you
and these life-saving actions
right now
local school officials are trying to
keep children safe in a pandemic while
their governor
picks a fight with them and even
threatens their salaries or their jobs
talk about bullying in schools
if they'll not help if these governors
won't help us beat the pandemic
i'll use my power as president to get
them out of the way
i'll i'll get governors out of the way
this is dictator talk guys
under under what article of the
constitution does it say that the
president of the united states under
article two what provision does it say
the president of the united states
without any statutory authority can run
roughshod over state authority on public
health matters where explain he doesn't
have any of that power but he's just
gonna run over them
and by the way his own people are saying
that they're using that kind of language
on a regular basis now that he's gonna
run right over people
you think dictatorships can't happen in
the united states you're watching the
formation of a dictatorship in the
united states right now under joe biden
that doesn't mean elections are going to
go away it does mean that you have a
permanent bureaucracy staffed by
unelected people who can be directed to
overrun your rights at the whim of a
person who is unanswerable to the public
except once every four years
and the legislature is a complete
vestigial organ of government
does that feel comforting to you in any
way
do you feel as though there are any
limits that prevent your rights from
being violated in this way
if the only way that you can stop the
operation of this sort of stuff is that
once every four years you can call a
halt on it maybe
does that really feel like your
constitutional rights are being well
protected
if the federalist institutions of
government go away this is why the
founders set up these institutions in
the first place as checks and balances
if all the checks and balances go away
and you're just elected and you're just
electing your dictator every four years
how is that freedom how is that liberty
the answer is it really isn't
okay
if i don't like what the governor's
doing i'm just gonna run over them by
the way
the notion that local school officials
are trying to keep kids safe and
pandemic with all of this masking and
all that again data how about some data
it's local school officials who kept the
schools closed in half the country for
most of last year it's only state
mandates that required the schools to be
open in blue areas in red states last
year
okay but let no good crisis go away he's
not going to finish with that we also
need to spend more money of course
here's joe biden declaring he's going to
spend more money
because of our vaccination program
and the american rescue plan which we
passed thoroughly in my administration
we've had record job creation for a new
administration
economic growth unmatched in 40 years
we cannot let unvaccinated
do
this progress undo it
turn it back
so tonight i'm announcing additional
steps to strengthen our economic
recovery
amazing we're gonna spend more money
good idea okay so biden closed by saying
it's equity all the way down we have to
focus in on communities of color what if
uh a lot of black people don't want to
get vaccinated you're just gonna have
them be fired and buy them from
restaurants because that seems kind of
bad
before i close
let me say this
communities of color are
disproportionately impacted by this
virus
and as we continue to battle kova 19
we will ensure that equity continues to
be at the center of our
response will ensure that everyone is
reached
okay and then he finished by uh by
saying that we all have to come together
so the unvaccinated are to blame the
governors are to blame everybody is to
blame except for joe biden who's the
actual one pushing dictatorial policy
now let's come together guys unity
we have the tools
now we just have to finish the job
with truth
with science with confidence
and together
as one nation
look we're the united states america
there's nothing not a single thing we're
unable to do if we do it together
so let's stay together god bless you all
and all those who continue to serve on
the front lines of this pandemic
and may god protect our troops
get vaccinated get vaccinated
i also think you should get vaccinated
but here's what i'm not willing to do
take an enormous diarrhea dump all over
80 million americans because i'm a
failure that's not that's not what i'm
willing to do joe biden's willing to do
that which apparently makes him a great
president by the way he just walked away
out no questions as per our usual
arrangement early birds dinner at
denny's is waiting and that re-run of
matlock that he's been that he's been
eager for
catch you later guys bye
[Applause]
[Music]
a country run by decrepit dictators
making policy at whim based on nothing
more than the political necessity of the
moment so here's the reality this thing
is likely never to take effect there
will be injunctions against it at the
state and federal level this will likely
end up at the supreme court of the
united states it is highly unlikely the
supreme court of the united states is
going to uphold it now you've heard a
bunch of idiots on twitter tell you that
this is definitely constitutional this
is definitely this mandate is definitely
going to be upheld by the courts and
they've been citing a few provisions of
law in an attempt to justify all of this
so let's go through this for just one
second so they like to cite a case from
1905 it's called jacobson versus
massachusetts hey in that case the
question was whether the state of
massachusetts could in fact compel
vaccination and what the court found is
that the state could
the court found quote the police power
of a state embraces such reasonable
regulations relating to matters
completely within its territory and not
affecting the people of other states
established directly by legislative
enactment as will protect the public
health and safety
while a local regulation even if based
on the acknowledged police power of a
state must always yield in case of
conflict with the exercise by the
general power of any by the general
government of any power it possesses
under the constitution the motor manner
of exercising police power is wholly
within the discretion of the state so
long as the constitution of the united
states is not contravened okay now the
first thing that you'll notice about
this decision is that this has nothing
to do with the federal government quote
it is within the police power of a state
to enact a compulsory vaccination law
and it is for the legislature and not
for the courts to determine in the first
instance whether vaccination is or is
not the best mode for the prevention of
smallpox and the protection of public
health so this is now two questions one
the federal government in a state number
two the argument being made here is that
the legislature is supposed to be making
the rules here right not at the
executive level
even maybe within a state okay so
jacobson is not good case law on point
here it does not relate to the case at
hand the federal government threw an
executive agency without explicit
authority to cram down this sort of
broad-based and heavy-handed regulation
on a hundred million americans
right that that is not what this case is
about in any way shape or form so
anybody anybody citing jacobs into you
has not read the case or just does not
care
okay then we come to the question of
what osha can do right the occupational
safety and health administration what
exactly can they do now there is a very
very solid case
that osha is actually
not
in a constitutional
administration
and the reason i say that is because the
enabling act for osha
is really really broad like way too
broad
i'm not writing that cass sunstein who's
a liberal writing from virginia law
review years ago talks about this 2008
is osha unconstitutional
he says that the occupational safety and
health act
is wildly broad
right there is no intelligible principle
that limits the exercise of agency
discretion
when the secretary of labor issues
regulations governing tractors ladders
or electrical equipment the only
question to be asked is whether one or
another standard is reasonably necessary
or appropriate
the agency is not required to do
whatever is necessary in order to
provide safe employment
its duty is to provide whatever is
reasonably necessary
even it can even reject what is
reasonably necessary so how does a how
does the osha administration decide what
is reasonably necessary or appropriate
completely vague there's no way to tell
what we do know is that historically
speaking osha has never been used for
anything remotely like this
the the infectious disease provisions
that osha has used have been entirely
related to social safety places like
nursing homes or healthcare providers
like a hospital
never has osha promulgated a broad-based
regulation on every private business
with over 100 employees in the country
telling them that they have to get
everybody vaccinated or test
this has never been promulgated that
would normally require some sort of
legislative action
so
there is serious question as to whether
osha on its face is constitutional but
even if you assume that it is
constitutional
the notion that you can extend osha's
authority over every business in the
united states with regard to infectious
disease which has never been tried
before is quite crazy
and and it is unprecedented
there are people who are talking about
this last year and this actually
subjects
the osha rules almost forthwith to
judicial review
so one of the big problems when it comes
to administrative agency action and this
is getting technical but it's really
important
is a stupid doctrine created by the
supreme court is called chevron
deference okay so the basic rule the
supreme court uses
is that if in exa if there's an
administrative agency let's call it osha
and there is a broad mandate that comes
from the legislature so the legislature
is filled with a bunch of callers and
idiots and they pass a law that says
osha can do whatever it wants right
that's the law osha can now do whatever
it wants so how do you exactly rein in
osha so there are a few different ways
that you can do it theoretically the
court can set reasonable and necessary
rules and now the court is actually the
lawmaker right the legislature delegated
to osha osha
can't define its own rules and now the
courts are going to define his rules or
their chevron deference chevron's
deference is the idea that an agency
because these are the experts are best
situated to interpret their own rules
okay which is kind of crazy
because now this means that you are
generally not allowed to appeal an
administrative agency decision to the
judiciary because the judiciary says
okay well you know we've washed our
hands of this instead this
administrative agency makes its own
rules because congress told them to make
their own rules we can't intervene in
that so you get to deal with them and if
they make their own rules which
coincidentally happen to side with them
well there's not much we can do about
that so chevron deference has been a
very difficult area of american law for
quite a long time
it's pretty certain that there is now a
majority on the supreme court to strike
down chevron deference
and go back to a time when the courts
routinely sort of drew limits around
what executive agencies could do and
tried to redefine the limits of how much
authority could be delegated from the
legislature to the executive branch
so ironically what joe biden could end
up doing here by promulgating such a
broad-based and dictatorial mandate via
osha which again its authority is not
clear in this realm at all
what they could end up doing
is having the supreme court step in
and wipe away
some of the fundamental bases for the
administrative state
which would be quite ironic that joe
biden in order to avoid blame for his
own economic failures and failures on
covet and in order to deflect attention
from afghanistan promulgates a
regulation that doesn't go into place
because it's badly written or badly
drawn and has no source authority it
ends up being elevated to the supreme
court level and the supreme court ends
up knocking out fundamental pillars of
the administrative state that the left
has relied on for literally a century in
order to promulgate regulations and turn
the executive branch into a quasi
legislature that could be a kind of
ironic result here
and frankly i think that there is a high
likelihood of that so maybe there is a
maybe there is a bright
lining to this very dark cloud which is
that we could see the administrative
state actually start to be paired back
here some of us have been concerned with
the administrative state for quite a
while it's time for the legislature to
seize back its authority if congress is
retaken by the republicans in 2022 this
needs to be first and foremost on the
schedule start defunding these agencies
and restricting their authorities and
drawing lines around them right now
don't submit budgets to the president of
the united states unless there are
strings attached to the executive
authority that is invoked by these
agencies we now have the cdc doing
eviction moratoria and osha telling
businesses that they have to man they
have to mandate vaccines among their
their workers
it's time to withdraw that authority
like right now and if democrats won't do
it republicans should run on it and if
republicans run on it and win they
should immediately move to restrict
administrative agency authority okay all
of that is assuming that we even get
past the first step here
and the first step is that joe biden
says that the osha
regulation he's going to promulgate is
going to be done under the emergency
temporary standards
okay emergency temporary standards have
typically not been used for stuff like
this in fact the last litigated
emergency temporary standard created by
osha was about
lowering the amount of asbestos that
you're allowed to have at a work site
and it was struck down
okay so
you could easily see a court saying this
is not an emergency temporary standard
you have to go through the normal
rule-making process which involves
public feedback and then the
promulgation of the rule and then maybe
litigation over the rule
joe biden just wants to do this like
super fast knowing that it's probably
gonna get held up in the same way that
he did the eviction moratorium knowing
that the court was immediately going to
enjoin it so i i have serious doubts as
to whether this thing ever is applied
but that's the whole point the whole
point here is to
assert the authority because it's a
win-win for joe biden according to his
own political light on the one hand if
the thing is upheld then he gets to play
dictator which is fun for him he likes
that on the other hand if the thing is
enjoined he gets to blame everybody else
for his own failures
he gets to say i've done what i can do
i've done what i can do but the bottom
line is really this we are now setting
the precedent
and it's multiple presidents who have
done this obama did it trump really
didn't
now biden's doing it
we have now set the precedent that
governance by executive order via
administrative branch fiat is going to
be the the only way that anything gets
done in this country from now on which
is incredibly incredibly dangerous
like super dangerous
okay meanwhile uh there are states that
are pushing back on all this as well
they should and so rhonda sanders in
florida he says we are going to fight
this with everything we've got
how could we get to the point in the
country where you would want to
have someone lose their job
because of their choice about
about the vaccine or not i mean
look some folks have reasons to do maybe
they're making the wrong decision but to
put to put them out of work and and send
them and not let them earn a living
because of this i just think that that's
fundamentally wrong and i think that the
more and more this has become coercive
where people have threatened mandates
and and firing and business consequences
the more it does that i think the more
people it alienates i don't think it
actually helps uh to get more people uh
to ultimately do it but i do not believe
that people should lose their jobs um
over this issue and um and we will fight
that
okay and uh he is not the only governor
who is saying that private businesses
are going to launch lawsuits on this
basis as well the bottom line is the
pushback has begun
and the the left has won for the course
of decades growth in government social
change through incrementalism and now
they've ditched the incrementalism over
the last year and a half two years they
really have just said we're going for
broke
whether it's blm declaring the entire
foundation of the united states corrupt
and evil and the democratic party going
along with that ideological move or
whether it is the biden administration
basically dismantling every single check
and balance they can find
whether it is surrender on the foreign
front or whether it is the complete
dictatorial top-down
approach of the of the left in
corporations the pushback is going to
begin because they have not been
approaching this in an incremental
fashion which is stupid politics more
but you know what i'm glad i'm glad
clarity is good so now we have some
clarity
our president wants to be a dictator he
doesn't care about the constraints of
his office
our media cheer him on
you know adults like joy reid or who are
cheering this stuff on
right she and by the way the the notion
that they keep on using of course is
that if you actually stand up for the
rights of americans it's because you
want people to die of covet
this is the this is the way stupid
people think about politics
we haven't seen uh desantis weigh in yet
but he's probably so busy dealing with
the what is the six or seven lawsuits
that he's already lost trying to force
covid onto you know he wants covet on
cruise ships he wants covet in the
schools he wants covet everywhere
apparently he wants to spread it
everywhere
he wants to spread it everywhere right
this is the sort of stuff that gets
pushed in our national media okay so you
have a choice as a citizen are you gonna
pay attention to people who lie to you
on a routine basis and give you
conflicting information on a routine
basis we tell you vaccines are effective
but also not effective and you should be
scared who tell you that the only way
for you to truly feel safe is to mandate
that your neighbor get fired if they
disagree with you on a particular issue
even when they pose no threat to you
what kind of america do you want this to
be and what kind of american do you want
to be because now joe biden has made
that choice extraordinarily clear so you
can either side with the tyranny right
inside against it those are your choices
alrighty we've reached the end of the
week but later today we have an
additional hour of content first you
can't forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you head on
over to dailywire.com at 7 pm eastern 6
pm central tune in i'm ben shapiro this
is the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pablo
wydowski associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin